when an 87 year old woman comes in
you're like
all right let's hike that skirt up mama
I just take a look at your teeth I
should have been a gynecologist I could
watch you all day do I password number
one reason I get it now
[Music]
I know some of you guys have heard of
this a man has been accused of
intentionally driving off a cliff with
his wife and two children
and a Tesla that one in a Tesla and is
now facing attempted murder charges
attempted they didn't die I thought they
all died no they didn't die how the [ __ ]
didn't they die is it because the Tesla
has automatic drive and they said no you
can't go off the cliff that's probably
what he wanted this is the Tesla holy
[ __ ] is so strong that looks like a
folded up napkin
it looks like one of those like litter
campaigns it's either crumple or cold
and that one is full oh crumpled yeah
did he try to kill himself too with his
family he tried to do a like do you
remember when we were streaks hiking in
Vegas to that one by [ __ ] the the
Hoover Dam yeah yeah and we saw all
these cars like that just on the side of
the uh
no I think like they're all cars that
flew off the side of the the the the
road and then they tumbled down and
you'll see like at least five of them
well sometimes they get dumped too
because I was in a play in high school
where we had a [ __ ] live Jeep but it
was like didn't work and afterward like
a bunch of the tech guys took it to just
like a cliff and just shoved it off and
like everyone like had like beers and
watched it fall and [ __ ] whoa that was
after the reviews were in so it was hot
yeah
funny thing to do sounds like such a
high school movie too dude it's just
toss a car I would have been stoked to
do that in high school that would be the
best [ __ ] ever watch a car tumble the
Drama teacher was like all right you
guys do whatever you want with it
because like we're done with the play
yeah so they shoved it off a cliff I
didn't go because I was too busy railing
chicks
after being the star of the show yeah I
was like come on high demand yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah so this do you know
that does it have the identity of him on
there the identity his name is dharmesh
Patel he's an Indian dentist he's aged
41 out of Pasadena
was that Angel's Crest or shout out
uh this man faces multiple uh charges
after driving off a cliff on PCH
oh it was uh he punched 250 to 300 feet
into a rocky Beach area known as Devil's
Slide about 20 miles south of San
Francisco oh why so old he that's a
that's a long road trip that they were
on it's a beautiful drive though isn't
it do you think he planned it or was it
like one of those things where he got
pissed when I drive PCH I'm like there's
so many places where you could drive off
a cliff yeah like I think about that a
lot but you couldn't because there's so
many cars in front of you and behind you
you never actually they're all trying to
go to American Apparel it's so it's so
stop start that you'd have to like go
one mile an hour off the cliff have you
guys been on the PCH though to San
Francisco it's I'm just like is this
California what the [ __ ] oh you mean
like when you pass Big Sur and all that
stuff yeah and you know gas is like
[ __ ] 11 bucks a gallon and [ __ ] yeah
it's amazing dude it's crazy they price
scouted but it is beautiful yeah it's so
beautiful that's a nice place to you
know run your family off a cliff yeah no
honestly as far as like Scenic wise it
is probably the top five places do you
think he planned it like I'm gonna make
it so [ __ ] beautiful when we all die
or do you think the kids were just like
in the car pissing them off and he's
like shut up I'm trying to have a good
family vacation you son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he sucked because they didn't die that
must be a crazy stressful threshold
though to like really scream everybody
survive that this is a really great ad
for Tesla safety that's what I'm gonna
say it [ __ ] it basically said that
the damage to the vehicle would indicate
that it hit and then flipped several
times onto 250 to 300 foot drop these
are guys yeah it did kind of yeah it
just becomes crumpled up wow yeah wow
because why don't you should just go to
the top of a building and then throw
each person off one by one and then you
jump at the end he probably snapped then
it must have been like an irrational
thing because if there wasn't any like
pre-planning like what Bart's plan was
that's a that's a good plan if you want
to kill your whole family I always find
it hard to believe that someone who's
who's like capable of doing that has
never thought about it once or twice
well I would maybe assume then that
instead of like going up to the top of a
building and one by one throwing people
off and making it look like a murder
there might have been the possibility of
maybe gonna look like an accident but
you're gonna die anyways who gives the
[ __ ] away right between yeah it's a it's
a murder suicide what do you think his
like dream outcome was by driving off
what if everybody else dies but him
he gets an insurance what if he's
religious though and he knows God's
watching he's like this has to look like
a [ __ ] accident
so I can get in all right I'm not
getting in God misdiagnosis it you go to
heaven and God's like dude I feel sorry
for your whole family God's like yo I
saw that dude he's like I'm so glad you
made it up here
are you guys all right
like he doesn't know the intent he gives
them a dab oh dude this one's on the
Gates of Heaven sweating like he's got a
fake idea at the bouncer like yeah he's
like at Customs like waiting for the
light he's all yo Banu Knievel what's up
he's like hey that was a Gnar way to go
dude
I did yeah that's how you go out this
guy's hardcore I wish we weren't done
writing the Bible dude he'd be in that
do you think everyone in Heaven it's
kind of like when a guy has 20 million
subscribers and everybody else in the
room has a couple thousand and like so
no matter what the guy says it's like
yeah yeah that's sick yeah like whatever
God says hey did you guys see that it
was crazy huh it's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah whatever you say dude that was
awesome you're God man yeah
what about fentanyl isn't that another
good way to die a good way to do it
seems like everyone has it these days
yeah we're just looking for more of a
guarantee yeah because he failed yeah
that's a high risk low reward kind of
thing you want to know the saddest
possible thing what how do you know you
know these things how do you know I mean
like in my nightmare mind I'm like how
sad would it be if this really was a
Tesla failure technologically and they
covered it up and made it blamed on it
how freaking sad how did they know that
that that's my question is how did they
know that it was intentional like he was
doing was he saying [ __ ] I'm killing all
of us yeah the wife was like he might
have the white was like he tried to kill
us yeah and then it just got uploaded to
the Tesla cloud and they heard that do
Teslas have a recording uh like a you
know how dash cams can record both
directions oh I don't know I know it
records outside unless he's screaming
sold out inside the outside her I don't
give a [ __ ] anymore
do you think that maybe maybe his wife
maybe his wife was backseat driving him
up the [ __ ] wall you know what I mean
she's like she's like oh my God will you
[ __ ] check the speed oh my God like
why'd you turn left too hard like just
the chances of that are extremely high
okay hear what it is or oh my God he
didn't want to stop at the Tesla
charging station and they were low on
battery and she was just was
[Laughter]
now we're gonna
write about that yep and then the kid's
like I'm hungry I want it I want that
and then the wife is like you see you
see these guys are hungry why'd you get
a Tesla we have a bunch of kids to throw
on [ __ ] orange slices around our
white interior and this guy's just like
orange slices
you know it just takes a bat all the way
up the wall yeah
it's crazy because it's not like he
doesn't like he has a like he went
through like med school right or dentist
school yeah so he's not like foreign to
having to work hard for [ __ ] for
something but he's not he's not I mean
he's foreign to Crime you know he's
smart but not that's not oh I think he
snapped he probably just snapped that
also reinforces that whole Dental
suicide stereotype oh yeah the highest
the highest rate of suicide assistant
dentist yeah why in what country
is it because of the teeth you just I
just take a look at your [ __ ] teeth I
should have been a gynecologist I could
watch [ __ ] all day
number one reason I get it now dude
that's why the guy does get into it
because all right that smells sticky
bread and you check this
ugly cavities the suicide rates of dinos
zero percent when an 87 year old woman
comes in you're like
hahaha
all right let's hike that skirt up mama
I like in Joe's mind like the guy's just
getting Ted's all [ __ ] day tens and
tens and tens the tightest and tightest
[ __ ] he's like a Barcelona dentist
in Brazil dude yeah
he's like a private browser's dentist
Eddie's got an age cut off he's like I
don't over 30 I don't do it he's got
DiCaprio age age limits you gotta
audition to get your teeth done or a
breast breast augmentation plastic
surgeon you know
if you had those jobs I mean even then
it's not like everyone who gets implants
is like a 10 either [ __ ] no you're just
cutting up boobs all day yeah
dude Joe's life is just a Brett Ratner
movie
every job even nuns are [ __ ] tense
Benny Hill sketch dude
it's Benny Hill show girls in laundry
just chasing all the time just chasing
and fast forward old women are MILFs
with huge tits
[Music]